well the purge of thoughtcrime continues
across the major tech platforms Praeger
you has quality thought-provoking videos
on a lot of topics but they generally
lean right-of-center nothing crazy
basically right-of-center so Facebook
has been suppressing their videos
because it's just too much for them
including this one defending the virtues
of masculinity when you try to make men
more like women you don't get less toxic
masculinity you get more the devaluation
of masculinity won't end well because
feminine passive men don't stop evil
passive men don't defend protect or
provide healthy families and strong
communities depend on the leadership and
bravery of good men yet the current
trend is to feminized young men in the
hopes of achieving some utopia notion of
equality and peace it's not masculinity
that's toxic it's the lack of it oh wait
that's totally true and that was a sum
total of it there was no graphic
violence no threats no burning crosses
and yet Facebook blocked its users from
seeing that video ultimately they
apologized after there was an outcry but
they did that which tells you a lot
Allie Stuckey is the host who you just
saw in that video she joins us tonight
so Allie was there something that we
didn't play was there more that was
deeply offensive no that was it you
played the most radical part this idea
that good strong men make for a good
strong Society several of Praeger used
videos were censored like you said only
two of them were taken down this was one
of them the specific reasoning for this
they said was that it constituted as
hate speech of course after fragrance up
on Twitter they apologized they said it
was a mistake and they put it back up
but of course you have to wonder how
many mistakes Facebook can make
exclusively at the expense of
conservative voices before it's
deliberate did they define hate speech
they throw the term around I have no
idea what it means did they tell you no
no of course not and that's really with
the troubling part about this is this
expansion of the word hate they're
Orwellian kind of monopoly on terms like
love hate right and wrong that's what
we're seeing from Facebook exclusively
censoring conservatives it's
unbelievable
did I know they have sensor to other
Praeger you videos they sincerely told
you this was just an absolute mistake we
had no idea how this happened did they
have a rational explanation no they
didn't at all because once preggers you
brought it up on Twitter it got
thousands and thousands of retweets
I guess Facebook realized this was going
to be a bigger deal than they wanted to
actually address so they said this was a
mistake we apologize and they put the
video back up of course by then a lot of
the damage had been done it probably
lost millions of views at that point it
was a new video but they never actually
explained their justification for
deleting it it'd be nice if Congress
kind of acted to protect the rest of us
from this but I guess they're they're
too busy doing something else Ali that
that's an amazing story thank you for
telling it to us